this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the show where we help people
build wealth do work that they really
love and that matters
and create actual amazing
relationships as opposed to fake
facebook friends yeah we want you to
have like real friends ones that'll show
up and help you change a tire and stuff
yup george campbell ramsey personality
host of the uh podcast the entree
leadership podcast which i just listened
to the one that dropped monday george
he's a rock star man it was really good
very well done any of you need
leadership information and
uh business information the entre
leadership podcast is one of the top
podcasts in the world one of the first
ones to step into that space many many
years ago doing it before it was cool it
was a podcast before this was a podcast
wow this was just on the radio
that's impressive
ahead of its time yeah we had we had it
as a podcast before i could spell
podcasts so there you go
okay open phones here we're going to
talk to you about all of your life in
other words that's what the ramsey
show's about it's about the whole thing
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five jasmine's in
dallas texas
hi jasmine how are you
hi dave i'm fine thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
talking to you
um hi george a little bit green uh use
the baby steps oh slow down you're gonna
have to get the end of your phone girl
you're you're talking off in a distance
we can't hear you speak directly into
you
can you hear me better now a little bit
let's try that
okay um i used the baby steps to get out
of bed in 2017.
lifelong listener and now i'm doing
estate planning
and i wanted to know would it be better
for myself and my family to have all my
assets tied up in a will
a trust or both
just a will
all you need is a will
uh there's only a couple times you would
use a trust uh
one is if you've got in excess of 20
million dollars you need to start
talking about doing some estate planning
that might involve a marital or an ab
trust it's talked about
if you have a special needs child
sometimes you will have a special have a
trust formed at your death to take care
of that called a special needs trust
money dumped into that trust to care for
that child
if you have minor children you can have
a trust formed at your death at the
direction of the wheel but you wouldn't
need to do it now uh that would just be
a family trust take care of your kids
until they reach 18. uh we had that set
up when our kids were minors and you can
put all of that just in the will
what you do need in addition to the
wills you need a healthcare powers of
attorney and a living will the living
will is the unplug or not unplug
document
you go ahead and tell everybody what's
going to happen and so they don't have
to go to court and argue about it
and the doc knows and the husband knows
and everybody knows it's all written
down this is what
jasmine wants to have happen if she's
comatose or whatever the situation is
and
you can lay all of that out and everyone
should it's uh it's a gift to the
rest of the family to not have to sit
and go well i don't know
i believe this and i believe that and
you know really what matters is what
jasmine believes in that situation yeah
and dave uh riddle me this i've heard
people say that well with a revocable
living trust you avoid probate and so
it's worth it to get a trust for that
reason what are your thoughts
probate in most states is three percent
and the tru the revocable living trust
will cost you more than three percent of
your assets
because most of the time they're fifteen
hundred to three thousand dollars to put
one together
and so uh a lot of the uh
not a lot some of the people in the
estate planning community have seen that
as a way to make money you make more
money if you set up the trust versus
help them get their will exactly exactly
you gotta have will anyway either way
you gotta have a will whether you have a
living irrevocable living trust or not
and there's a lot of problems with their
revocable living trust i wouldn't fool
with one matter of fact my net worth is
way in excess of 20 million i don't have
a living trust
at all everything i have
i see i i don't even have a trust i've
got a bunch of companies and llcs that
will no we do have one trust on one
piece of property that's set it had to
be set up that way so one reason to do
it is to protect some of your assets by
sending them into the llc or a business
entity exactly and so you know
but again if you've got
huge
so let's say you had
uh ten million dollars three percent
would be
um three hundred thousand dollars in
taxes you might think if you had a ten
million dollar asset and your state it's
a state tax is a probate tax it's not
federal you got no federal income no
federal taxes on in the state of 10
million dollars but if you're gonna
leave 10 million dollars in a state that
has a three percent probate tax that's
going to cost them 300 grand
okay so
now
you might if it's all let's say it's a
10 million dollar piece of property
if you put that in an irrevocable living
trust it's a fairly singular transaction
it's easy to manage it's not a big
problem not a lot of stuff going on
uh and so forth uh but
and that you know you'd spend three
thousand dollars in legal fees and save
300 then that's fine you don't own the
property more the trust now owns the
property but you're the beneficial
interest and you're in control the trust
so it's all the same thing
the problem with the the this thing
though that and jasmine so you just need
to go to like mamabearlegalforms.com get
your will done and do a living will
which is a healthcare power of attorney
and unplug or not unplug deal that's
simple just do the basic documents for
an estate plan unless you have a sizable
estate and then you can start talking
about that but here's the thing george
let's go back into it because let's just
get down the nerd weeds a minute the
nerd weeds on this this is my favorite
place to be
nerd weeds
we need a weed eater so it okay if let's
say you had uh 10 million dollars worth
of assets and you didn't want to pay the
300 000
but it's like 25 or 30 different things
okay
now you've got to retitle all of your
mutual funds
all of your
anything you want to hide from this
probate tax
you have to reset the name on it
re-title your car retitle your house
nothing can be retitle the family farm
into the name of the trust anything
that's not in the name of the trust is
subject to probate tax
so what happens is i read an article on
financial planning magazine a couple
years ago
78 of the time this eight out of 10
times people spend 1500 to 3 000 have
this trust which is basically a
a hollow thing you have to put things in
the bucket it's a bucket yeah you have
to put things in the bucket
and then they then they never move the
titles to the stuff into the bucket so
it's just an empty trust so it's an
empty shell there's nothing in there and
so they still get all the taxes and so
the reason i didn't start with that
years ago i had a guy recommend it years
ago was i got looking at it i went every
time i saw a dadgum car i got to go
through a trust movement every time i
saw a piece of real estate i could go
through a trust movement screw it i'm
just gonna you know no
but now i do have a um this property
right here which is worth
i don't know 500 million dollars or
something it's all sitting in one trust
and that's for beneficiary for the
probate aspect but also
now all the gains on this property from
the time
above what we've put into it which it's
appreciated right uh well no i
appreciate as as it goes up in value
generations don't pay taxes on it estate
taxes aren't so it removed the whole
thing
except for the original cost from the
estate tax equation so
huge move from that standpoint
definitely worth it and but again it's
one piece of property i got no hassle
factor i'm not having to move stuff in
and out yeah i'm gonna work with
trustees and lawyers every time i make
some transaction i'm not able to write
checks out of a trust bank oh god it
drives me nuts so no it's it's very very
impractical for 99 percent of the people
out there don't screw with it there we
are we're out of the nerd we thank you
for taking us there this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so dave we just celebrated memorial day
and coming up we have independence day
but there's another holiday that is one
of my personal favorites and that is
national insurance awareness day i know
you're a big fan we celebrate every year
we throw a big party with george
sarcasm will get you everywhere
i'm just national insurance awareness
it's a real day it's a real day mark
your calendars june 28th we're throwing
a party
oh really that's about as exciting as a
tupperware party
people don't know what that is george
i'm i'm that old yeah here's the thing
we we talk about insurance a lot on the
show and we like to nerd out on it but
it's one it's one of the most crucial
things people need to get in place and
here's the bad news there's a lot of
crappy types of insurance you don't need
some crazy types and there's only a
select few that are actually helpful as
you build wealth to protect your assets
absolutely you know the big thing we
always teach in financial peace
university and i've taught for years is
the
the thing you want to use insurance for
is to cover things you can't afford
okay so if you're broke
and you don't want to self-insure
through a five thousand dollar car you
can't afford to lose that car you need
to have it insured right uh if you got
five hundred thousand dollars in the
bank
and you're driving a ten thousand dollar
car you could self-insure that if you
want to but insurance is for
transferring the risk
of things that you cannot
handle the risk like the burning down of
your house most people that would
destroy their lives financially
and so you got to transfer that risk and
we've heard countless really sad stories
on the show people calling in with
whether it's a house fire or someone
died without you know term life
insurance in place or they didn't have
the right health insurance and they go
bankrupt because of medical bills and so
it's one of the things that yes we like
to have fun and make fun of the fact
that insurance is boring but it's one of
the most important things you need if
you're going to follow the ramsey plan
you've got to have the right types of
insurance in place and one of the main
types is home and auto these are two of
your biggest purchases you'll ever make
your biggest assets you've got to have
the right home and auto a lot of people
have auto right it's the law but they
may not have enough coverage inside of
that policy so that's one of the main
areas you've got to look at and go do i
have enough
to cover if i need this home insurance
you're walking around 100 000 worth of
liability you're a lawsuit looking for a
place to happen somebody's going to sue
you into bankruptcy if you're getting a
bad wreck because 100 000 won't cover 10
minutes in the hospital for the other
guy that you hit accidentally yeah and
it's called an accident for a reason you
would never do it on purpose but the
guy's in the hospital it's your fault
that family is going to come after you
and the insurance company's going to
write a 100 000 check so fast and it's
going to leave you on the hook for the
other half million in icu bills and your
bankrupt you've got to have the
coverages on the liability side it's a
big deal that's a big one and uh with
that there's umbrella insurance we talk
about this and people go do i need
umbrella insurance and this sits kind of
on top of those home and auto policies
to cover you in case of those lawsuits
and we tell people not to worry about
umbrella insurance unl until you've
built a certain level of wealth yeah you
got a half million million dollar net
worth now you're a target if something
happens go ahead and pick you up a
million dollar house if someone bumps
into dave ramsey and a fender bender
they're going i just said dave ramsey
payday yeah ding ding
yeah don't try it by the way if you're
driving behind dave don't just hit him
for fun please don't do that well you'd
have to catch me but the um
so anyway the the
the thing is the umbrella policy is only
a couple hundred bucks usually two two
hundred fifty three hundred dollars uh
for an extra million dollars worth of
coverage it's it's a really good buy
yeah and we do recommend and the reason
it's cheap is because you rarely have to
use it but when you do
you're really glad it's there yeah once
your coverage runs out on your current
policy so that's a good one to remember
as you start building wealth another one
uh we just we just took a call about
wills but term life insurance alongside
a will is so so important if anyone
relies on your income for term life and
a will for everyone every single
american needs a will yeah 15 to 20
years
of level term and the amount you would
buy be about 12 times your income 10 to
12 times 20 say but 12 is good so if you
make 50 000 a year you got 600 000 on
you you die mom put 600 000
into some mutual funds it creates 50 to
70 000 worth of income we have replaced
the income that you used to create for
your family that's the purpose of life
insurance nothing else all your
investments ought to be in investments
not in life insurance yes don't trust
anyone who wants you to get into whole
life because it's a great investment on
top of being life insurance terrible
deal you never knew that and 2021 here's
a sad stat 55 percent of americans
didn't have a will which means family
fights which means the government and
courts deciding what happens i don't
like that future for anyone i i've seen
numbers higher than that i i think it's
a lot higher than that but anyway it's
too many don't have too many
another one is health insurance and most
people hopefully have this in place i
took a call last week where someone
didn't have health insurance and as my
a1 you need to get health insurance
today and it's because medical debt has
been the number one cause of bankruptcy
in the u.s it's so easy to bankrupt on
we just heard a team member story of
being in the hospital million dollar
bill luckily they had insurance but
that's the bill yeah yeah and the number
one cause and it's not even necessarily
the million dollar bill that bankrupts
somebody it's you got no
insurance i mean the co-pays
alone can get you you know but
you know healthy if you think okay what
is the number one cause of bankruptcy
medical bills
the number one way to get rid of that
health insurance it's a no-brainer you
got to do it and even if you don't have
it through your employer if you can get
it in the marketplace do it whatever you
can get it you can get obamacare i mean
it's it's out there and you know a lot
of states blue cross blue shield or
whatever and but jump in there and get
some health insurance go with an hsa a
lot of times that's going to be cheaper
for you at least get the big stuff
covered so it doesn't bankrupt you yes
and if you're healthy i love a good high
deductible healthcare plan with an hsa
that's what i do here at ramsey me too
and it's a great option alongside that
long-term care something a lot of people
don't have in place we recommend getting
this when you're 60 or older to cover
nursing home stays in-home care things
that can rack up really quickly yeah 300
000 is your exposure on that typically
statistically and that's about all you
can get in coverage anyway
and so you get covered for about 300
grand and that keeps
if you're very wealthy and you got 5 or
10 million dollars you can self-insure
if you're completely dead dog broke well
you're going to be on welfare anyway
called medicaid and the government's
going to provide nursing home but if
you're ever everyone else who's in the
middle between those two things and
you're over 60
75 of you ladies will outlive your
husbands
and so what happens is papa goes in the
nursing home they got 300 000 in savings
they end up spending it all on papa's
care he dies mama's left broke
and that's from not having good
long-term care life insurance or
long-term care insurance don't put life
insurance in there that's why it slipped
out i was just going to remind you that
they're starting to bundle it with some
life insurance don't do that don't
bundle it with savings simple nursing
home or in-home care
insurance and it typically is going to
cover around three years four years
worth of coverage is about all you can
get and three or four hundred thousand
dollars is what you're really at risk
for yeah so for your 60th birthday gift
yourself the gift of long-term care
there you go there you go um long-term
disability another one
very different but this provides an
income for you and your family if you
can't work
and this is something a lot of people
don't have in place it's one of the most
underinsured areas uh because people
just don't look at it that much and
really your the one stat i saw said
you're 12 times more likely to become
disabled than to die by age 60. wow and
so if you're if you're like 25 so
disability is a bigger problem than
death in other words yeah um
plus you got to hang around with you so
that's true there's that's there's that
part too so you know you need to get
long-term disability don't bother with
short-term disability it's gimmick
insurance you're going to have your
emergency fund in place you've got that
to cover you know you're going to have a
good plan you're going to be working the
rams you plan all that kind of stuff but
long-term disability if you can get it
through work or through a group plan of
some kind it's by far the cheapest yeah
and that's what we have here at ramsey
it's covered thank you dave we provide
it because honestly it's not that
expensive
as a benefit for an employer to provide
if you're a small business person it's
something you can actually buy for your
team
unless you're in a blue collar trade
which the trade you're in will affect
your disability insurance
more than your age or even your health
makes sense so if you're you're working
with your hands and you know you're
swinging uh you know three tons of
i-beams around
harder to get coverage on long-term
disability than it is if you're flying a
desk if you're flying a desk jockey yeah
well the last one's identity theft
protection not quite an insurance but
very important to have in place as more
and more people are shopping online i've
experienced this luckily we have
xander's id theft protection for our
whole team they help me avoid a 600 hour
mess so here's the deal we threw a lot
at you we just launched a five day
series an interactive guide i'm gonna
walk you through this stuff in less than
three minutes a day you can go sign up
for this at ramseysolutions.com
slash confidence i promise it's the most
exciting insurance video series ever
created because which is a low bar solo
i jumped over it so go sign up
ramseysolutions.com
confidence you'll thank me later it's
called confidence in your coverage and
all joking aside it's really good george
has done a great job with this five-day
interactive guide confidence in your
coverage go watch it it's free
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five maurice
and zee are with us in phoenix arizona
says on my screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
yes dave what's going on man thank you
it's good to hear from you all you too
congratulations how much have you paid
off
we paid off 62 000 a day in 10 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time
it was 135 000 days oh i love it good
for you so what kind of debt was the 62
so the debt consisted of it was three
grand from the irs and then also fifty
nine thousand dollars from navient we uh
kicked navi not to basically basement
get rid of ugly uncle naviant
i love it
that's right yeah he's a brother to
sally may brother and sister of ugly
they might be kissing cousins they're
brother and sister of ugly i love it you
guys are awesome man congratulations
what made you decide to do this uh 10
months ago
honestly dave i got put on to you in
2017 for my cousin ashley and she gave
me the total money makeover and so i
read that and then i also um
was able to hear one of your uh
you was talking about how to become an
everyday millionaire on youtube and so
after hearing that i was just sold
because you know where i'm from we only
talk about you know becoming a
millionaire you have to you know
play a professional sport or just you
know blow up and be famous so after i
heard that you know regular people can
do it i was just sold and then i put my
then you know girlfriend z on to you
back then in 2017.
yeah and so back back then i um i only
had a car payment that's pretty much the
only debt that i ever carried and i was
living with my parents and i wanted to
move out and so i was like um i read
your total money makeover
and i was like wow i literally could you
know just pay off my car payment i'm
living rent free i don't really have
bills like why am i sitting on this so
um i paid my car off fairly quickly and
moved out on my own and the rest is
history
wow all right how long have y'all been
married
we've been married for a year and four
months dave okay so when you get married
you decide all right we're really doing
this
whatever debt is left we got to clean up
and it's old uncle naviant
yes dave and unfortunately you know i
brought the dead into the marriage so
well yeah when we got married we cash
flowed our wedding that was uh consisted
of 20 grand and then we hit the ground
running dave um just you know working
extra jobs i remember working you know
six seven days a week sometimes um zee
was also putting in extra work as well
and um delaying you know that
gratification right and just um
not going on vacation you know telling
friends no you know we want to go out
and we were just locked in and have the
tunnel vision days wow what was the
highest paying side job you guys did
i would say the highest paying side job
i did was officiating youth football on
the weekend i don't know i'm making
pretty good money doing that yeah it was
fun man what should i pay
it pays uh fifty dollars a game day so i
would do anywhere from four to five uh
sometimes six games on saturday oh wow
that can add up crushing it that's good
so you guys saw what was on the other
side of debt freedom and that excited
you
absolutely and you were willing to do
whatever it took to get there in 10
months and we're not talking about you
know eight years of sacrificing and not
living and doing these side jobs for 10
months you can do just about anything
yeah but i got to go back maurice i'm
there's probably a story i'm troubled by
i don't understand you started in 2017
but you didn't really start
well
i started uh by uh i paid off my car so
that was like one of the biggest things
but
um so yeah i think i think though what
i'm saying is when z came into the
equation
you got with it
oh absolutely i kicked it into high gear
for sure that's what the calendar tells
me about the time she showed up we got
rid of uncle navian
right exactly right it was a lot of
theory until z and z is kicking in gear
now
am i missing something yeah no i'm
definitely a numbers person and so in
order to come into this marriage um
worries knew like okay we actually have
to have a plan we have to get this done
yeah and there's no way that this was
just gonna linger around in our marriage
so yep
mari's take take notes on this because
next time you bring something up she's
gonna make you do it okay i'm just
saying
i like it this is good y'all are awesome
you're fun way to go i'm so proud of you
how's it feel to be free
man it feels great day just to be able
to you know um once the bills are
covered just to look at the budget and
just see all that extra freedom that we
can do you know where you know um
right now you know saving for a home
right now so that's exciting so it just
feels amazing just to it gives a better
sense of peace you know going to bed at
night and then also too it relieved a
lot of tension within our marriage as
well yeah
you know i do i do love what you said
earlier maurice when you said um because
you're like me you said i came from a
neighborhood where we thought the only
way to you know be wealthy was to be
famous or something and be an athlete or
somehow become famous and uh when you
actually understand the numbers and you
start to go hey if guys that come from
neighborhood like maurice or dave can do
this anybody can do this right uh and
and that's that's a good message for
everybody to hear
absolutely dave yeah absolutely um yep
absolutely um because you know
just like you said dave you know where
i'm from you know that's this is what
you see you know just people going to
the nfl or nba but
people don't talk about the grind um
just living under your means right
living debt free and that that provides
a lot of freedom in your life so yes
that's absolutely correct well proud of
you guys again so so awesome who are
your biggest cheerleaders outside the
two of you who was saying go for it you
can do
it yeah we had a ton of family and
friends who knew about us being on this
journey and they would cheer us on but i
have my best friend sydney who um you
all got to speak with her a couple of
months ago she called in and did her
debt free screen from phoenix as well i
remember we started our journey together
at the beginning and um we actually
finished around the same time i remember
calling you know after a long day at
work and things of that matter and we
would call each other and just talk
about like what the first thing we were
gonna buy when we were debt free what we
were gonna do and so it just
um it was really nice just having her
along this journey with us we kind of
were a trio here that's cool that's very
good yeah well we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure you
guys are on your way maurice you're
going to be a baby steps millionaire man
i want to talk to you on the uh
on that uh hour when we're doing that
hour one of these days and i'll remember
talking to you today when that happens
and also send you a copy of total money
makeover which uh you can hand out to
someone and get them started that's what
got you started i'm also going to send
you a one-year subscription to financial
peace in every dollar through ramsey
plus
and if you've not been
if you've not been through it you guys
go through it as a wedding gift if you
have been through it and you want to
give it away to somebody and get them
started a lot of people buy these
one-year subscriptions and give them
away so whatever you want to do we're
going to send it to you either way and
we're just proud of you guys way to go
amazing thank you thank you so much dave
i appreciate it man you bet maurice and
z
phoenix arizona 62 000 in 10 months
making 135 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two
one
[Applause]
i love
it that's how it's done right there man
you don't need to weigh it on student
loan forgiveness you can just kick uncle
navient out yourself
it's more enjoyable that way and he's
the bothersome old uncle you know not
the cool uncle a little creepy he's not
he's the creepiest he's hanging around
he's in the bedroom won't leave
he just sleeps asking for money every
month
wants money all the time
he's always standing around with his
hand out that's i mean and he learned it
from his from his you know his cousin
sally so i mean and they're just they're
just they're everybody's got relatives
one or two like that that you just don't
want living with you no uncle navier and
sally they gotta go people they gotta
they get their own place and let me just
tell you uncle joe's not going to get
rid of him
he's uh
he's going to talk about it but he's an
enabler
that's a good way to put it
never heard it said that way
in so many ways this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
imagine the energy of a jam-packed arena
filled with people ready to experience
what it means to live life to the
fullest
picture that with your favorite speakers
on one stage empowering you with tools
and principles that will create
unstoppable momentum in your life
that
is one of our live events that is smart
conference we just came back from 3 000
folks business leaders in orlando at
entree leadership for four days
and before that we had 3 500
on a thursday night there in orlando for
a building wealth live event with george
and me and rachel and dr john deloney
and um who else was there ken coleman
was there yeah so uh the smart
conference is expanded version of
everything
it is leadership it's wealth it's
achieving your goals it's your
relationships it's your mental health
it is uh your career we're going to
spend the entire day your marriage uh
pastor craig groschel amy groschel from
life church are going to be there
talking about marriage
we're going to touch on every
area
every area
wow
pretty cool and you don't want to miss
this tickets are only 39
that's a great price for a full day
event like this
it is uh it is about 50 sold out it is
going to be in dallas
and it will be october the 22nd all day
that saturday
go ahead and get your tickets now before
they get sold out if you haven't noticed
anything that is a live event people are
gravitating to like never before our
events are selling out very very quickly
uh fastest in a long long time ready to
get out so uh everything we're touching
right now selling out uh we're all we
have nothing left but fall events right
now anyway and they're all
50 to 75 85 sold out and they're still
months and months and months away so if
you want tickets to these at 39 bucks
for the whole day amazing you will leave
the day smart that's how it works all
right matt is with us in new york city
hey matt how are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
nothing much so i have a uh you know a
couple questions regarding my finances
so i'm 22 years old i'm currently
serving in the united states
air force in the air national guard
and i'm about six thousand dollars right
now in debt
i'm looking to
move out of my parents house who i'm
currently living with right now looking
to move out of their house in about two
to uh you know three to four years and
get my own place down in florida
but i do not have any sort of uh
discipline whatsoever when it comes to
saving money and budgeting okay hard
stop hard stop i gotta catch up here
you're in the
army national guard did you say
air uh air national guard international
guard okay and you're how old
i'm 22. and that's a part-time gig or a
full-time gig
that's a part-time gig okay what do you
what's your full-time job
yes sir what is your full-time job
i'm a
private investigator
okay
and you're
the national guard is typically done
state by state is it not
can you transfer to florida
yes i can
okay
but you went through a boot camp a
regiment to to join right
yes sir
and they taught you
discipline right
um sort of we were
i
went to boot camp um amidst this covet
so it was it was really um you know sort
of short-handed with the boot camp and
discipline and what they can do and what
they can't do
um and everything like that
the shorter version so what do you make
as a private investigator
your phone is screwed up you need to
speak directly into it
can you hear me yes sir that's better
thank you
thank you so i work about 50 50 to 55
hours weekly
the pay is 18.50 an hour
and so why does it take three years to
move to florida
just just saving up money um you know
you make plenty of money you must be
partying your butt off yeah matt where's
the money going currently do you know
i
really have no uh really have no save
with that i really don't i really don't
know um i think it's i think it's more
so my problem of going out during the
week and not budgeting and not saving my
life yeah
every night yeah
well it sounds like there's your problem
and there's your solution i think we
need to stop going out and start getting
on a budget making a plan having a goal
set in front of us which you told me
your goal is to move out so i'm going to
use that to fuel my savings habits and
go you know what i'm going to cook at
home and if they want to hang out they
can come to my place i'll go to their
place we're going to do this on the
cheap because i got goals i'm going to
get out of this 6 000 in debt i'm going
to have an emergency fund so i don't
have to worry about
you know getting that next paycheck if
it doesn't show up and then we're going
to go about the business of saving up to
get out of that house and i don't think
you need to be buying a house right now
go rent somewhere even if you moved to
florida for a while yeah
i mean i i think you could be debt-free
move out everything within just a few
months here
but you're going to have to really make
every dollar that you have behave
and so here here's a rule i always use
matt um
you can't out earn your stupidity i
tried
you can't make enough to not know where
the money's going
no one can make that much that's how
people make 10 million dollars as an
athlete look up a few years later and
they're broke
because they have no id and they say the
same thing you said the same thing i
used to say i don't know where i went oh
i don't know where it went
and so you don't want to wake up that
way at 30 years old man you're calling
it 22. the great news is you're only 22.
uh and so it's time to get with it um
time to throw your shoulders back
and be grown up and stuff
and uh that means you're going to tell
you i want you to pretend like you're
managing this money
for someone else and it's your job
to manage the money well
and if you don't manage the money well
you're going to get fired
because you suck at your job
pretend that
and that helped me because as a as a
christian i started going this isn't my
money it's god's
and i suck at managing god's money and
then i want him to give me more
to which he laughs and says no
i hear you suck at handling my money
[Laughter]
it's in the bible i like pictures yeah
is that second opinions that's where
that one came from no it's in the
parable of the talents actually oh yeah
but yeah yeah when you when you don't
manage well he not only doesn't give you
more he takes it from you and gives it
to the one who does manage well it's in
the bible and so yeah
and that that's the thing you always
tell audiences uh
matt i'll tell you pretend like you were
managing money for a company called you
incorporated and your job was to manage
money for you incorporated
that's your job now be good at your job
as soon as you do that you're to find
you got money everywhere
and you're going to be looking at your
party bubbas and saying nope nope nope
nope nope
22. there's lots of bigger goals than
drinking beer all night got bigger goals
smoking dope all night i got bigger
goals in this we've got stuff to do here
we're gonna uh like be a grown-up pal
for that move out of the house go to
florida
got bigger goals you want to live a
grown-up life you got to do grown-up
stuff
and you know me i mean 62-year-old
children
and i meet 22 year old grown-ups
so it's not an age thing it's just a
matter of
the one definition of maturity is
learning to delay pleasure for a greater
good
and so am i willing to pay a price for
something better
am i willing no discipline seems
pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
the way we say it around here is
that way and we also say
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else
but that requires having a vision for
your life there you go where there is no
vision that people perish and so you've
got to have those goals in front of you
or else you won't have any real reason
to manage your money well
honestly it is easier to overeat over
drink and be broke
except for the part when you wake up
it's fun for us and you're fat and
hungover and broke i mean you know it's
a problem
and so you know it's easier in the
moment
you know but but it's easier in the long
term because here's the thing a guy who
used to work for you tell me this whole
time he said you're going to pay a price
you're either going to pay a price now
so you win
or you're going to pay the price of not
having paid a price and live a life of
mediocrity
and the life of mediocrity is the price
you pay
for being a half-butt
and he would look at me and go dave
don't be a half-butt
which i never really figured out exactly
what a half butt is but i just didn't
want to is full butt the goal then i
well it's apparently i am but there you
go
shut up george
i'm here for your entertainment america
that's all
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print podcast on ramsey
networks is my co-host today as we take
your calls about your life and your
money
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five mary
starts off this hour in new york city hi
mary how are
you hi dave how george um thanks for
taking my call sure what's up um
so my boyfriend and i have been dating
about a year and a half now and
we
obviously keep budgeting and find
interest separate and everything but
i've learned that we have definitely
very different backgrounds when it comes
to money he has grown up
where he doesn't really think about
money things are just kind of paid he
spends what he wants he doesn't really
think about it and i am the exact
opposite
um and as we're looking into the future
and
you know what that means for our
relationship i would like us to get on
the same page so i've started talking to
him about that because i know he has a
little bit of credit card debt but he
doesn't really know and he doesn't
really pay attention because it's never
really he's never thought about it he's
really really open to learning so i
started actually playing your show for
him but i'm realizing very quickly that
there's a lot of information that i have
learned from listening to your show that
i'm just
not
really it's just so much information i
don't know how to like teach it to him
without getting overwhelmed i'm just
wondering where we should start as we
look to the future and
you know what that means for us and how
i can help him you know get us get on
the same page wow that's awesome well
you you sound very mature how old are
you
i'm 28. and how old is he
27.
okay
very cool well you know t trying to
teach him all the stuff and go well
here's what you need to be doing i don't
know that that's going to work in the
long term
what i would do is start to create a
vision for the future and then these
principles become a part of how you get
there it becomes the game plan
that would get me more excited if i'm in
his shoes personally
yeah rather than um
you you and you don't want to become his
mom
you didn't sign up for that and he
doesn't want you to become his mom you
really don't want to be that and so
george is right let's pull him in
instead of pushing him in that sense um
so it might sound something like this
mary here's some actual things you could
say okay
the number one cause of divorce in north
america today
is money fights and money problems
so if we're going to be married someday
and you know it seems like we're moving
in a positive direction with this
relationship
then we at some point before we're
married need to address the number one
cause of marriage problems
to ignore that would be like stupid
right right
and so i mean if the number one
cause of death of male four-year-olds is
bear attacks well you keep male
four-year-olds away from freaking bears
i mean this is not hard right you know i
mean what i made that up but i mean you
know what i'm saying right so whatever
it is this is the number one cause and
so
it's not number three it's number one
so i mean if we can protect our marriage
and i love you and if we can protect our
future relationship and i love you
against the number one problem we should
really get the
the antidote ahead of time we ought to
drink a bottle of the antidote right and
so
we gotta begin to talk about that how's
that sound to you and he's gonna go well
yeah that makes sense because it does
make sense well and here's the thing
i grew up one way you grew up another
way i'm a lot more of a tight wad a lot
more administrative minded you're i'm
kind of the nerd of the two you're kind
of the free spirit of the two so it's
not as natural for you to freak out
about this stuff and i stay freaked out
about it all the time
great so you need to tighten up a little
i need to loosen up a little and we need
to learn to work together and be
grown-ups together on our future goals
and you know here's a format we could do
this in like we could take financial
peace university as a
relationship building class although it
happens to be a money class
right yeah he's very open to that he
really wants to learn that i
one positive thing is that he definitely
does not want me to just tell him what
to do yeah um he wants to learn he knows
how important this is to me and good
then you're marrying a man and not a
little boy
yeah that's good yeah
he wants to learn i just i don't know
how to teach him i guess i don't want
you to teach him
i don't want you to teach him
i want him to want to learn
and he'll find it okay if you put our
stuff in front of him he'll learn it
he just needs to reason he needs a
reason to go do it
you know and the reason is is that it's
not my nature to go do this this is him
talking to himself
but
uh this woman mary is worth it
and she's telling me this is kind of you
know it's kind of permission to play
here you know if we're going to be in
this i'm going to have to deal with this
and so i you know this ain't going away
i got to deal with this so i'm going to
go in here and learn this stuff and get
good enough at it so that i get married
right mary have you been through
financial peace university
no no i haven't okay well let me let me
make that uh our gift to you guys if
you're willing if he's willing to go
through it obviously you are so that's
one year of ramsay plus it includes all
the videos in financial peace university
and every dollar premium and if you guys
start to lay this out and start to have
that vision i think it'll get him
excited about doing the plan instead of
being forced into it it's the best
pre-marriage or pre-marriage counseling
there is because it addresses the number
one thing
i'll give you the next three if you want
them
all the marriage all the marriage data
says if you can be in agreement on money
religion
kids whether to have them and how to
treat them or is are the inmates going
to run the asylum or are you
and uh
and in-laws
the crazy people in each of your family
how are you going to keep how are you
going to keep them at bay
if you can deal with the in-laws and the
outlaws and the kids
and the religion
and the money and you get on the same
page of that and you've had deep
good rich discussions in your
pre-marriage counseling process you have
like a 90 probability of having a
successful marriage
those are the big four that break the
four horse one of the apocalypse that
break up more marriages than anything
else and that's what all the data from
the marriage people tell us and we found
all of that because we discovered we had
the number one
that's pretty amazing though if you know
that going in you go well yeah let's do
everything we can to be aligned in all
those areas i hate god i love god
they're gonna be troublesome not gonna
work out don't be troublesome you know
um i don't want kids at all i don't even
like them i don't want to be near them i
want 17. there's going to be a problem
talk about that beforehand yeah we need
to know these things don't wake up later
and go why no
you know you need to know you talk about
it ahead of time and
you know and go ahead and just identify
aunt
and sally may over there she's the crazy
one
and uh you were just and she's not
living here
she she's live she's been homeless she's
lived with every other cousin and she's
not living with his cousin i'm just
telling you because she's drunk all the
time and she's not living here let's go
ahead and get this second problem get
this out in the open all right and just
go ahead and deal with it now because
it's gonna come up yes gonna come up
can't avoid it never happened in my
house but it's going to come up
[Laughter]
sharon just says what we're going to do
and then it's over that's a good man
there you go
happy wife happy life this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're a business or you're an hr
leader you know your employees are
dealing with
a lot
my employees wellness team financial
wellness team smart dollar just did a
study
that found out after living through one
of the toughest times in history 60
percent
of employees say their mental health has
gotten worse
half say their mental health keeps them
from doing their job to the best of
their ability
good leaders take their employees mental
wellness seriously because it's good
for them it's good for you it's good for
your team it's good for your business
it's good for your customers when your
employees are healthy mentally so give
your employees a way to deal with their
stress and put them on a path to care
for their mental wellness john dolone's
anxiety relief checklist gives your
employees simple steps
they can take to relieve their anxiety
so they can start bringing their full
selves to work again it's completely
free to use to get john dalone's anxiety
relief checklist for employees
go to ramsey solutions dot com slash
anxiety checklist again ramsey solutions
dot com slash anxiety
checklist
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
kat is with us in pittsburgh hey kat
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you today thank you for
having me my honor what's up
um yes i just wanted to give you a
little bit of background about me um
i'm married
currently we just got mark and i just
got married on may 7th
and um we are currently debt free
um thanks lord
and um we have approximately um about 70
to 80 k in liquid
and we make collectively right around 70
to 75 yearly
and what we are doing right now is we're
renting an apartment
so with our rental um rent utilities our
expenses are right around 850 to 900 a
month
um and right now we do have some crypto
investments and we'd really like to get
into retail um i'm sorry real estate
investment as well
but we're not sure if maybe either
moving into a duplex for our first home
would be
the right choice as far as making
um you know having a place to move into
and obviously making some investment on
the other side of that duplex
or if maybe we should like buy a smaller
home fix it up and within a year's time
maybe move out of that to another one
and then just rent that home out or flip
it
but that's what we wanted to ask you
okay
well i think a uh a precursor to the
answer is uh the rule that we use at
ramsey is we give you we answer your
questions of what we would do
knowing what we know
if we woke up in your shoes
okay
and uh i by the time i started with
nothing and by the time i was 26 i
bought four million dollars worth of
real estate
i was doing flip this house before chip
and joanna were born
okay literally i mean i'm not kidding
it was early 80s right and um no
disrespect to them but because they're
wonderful but the uh um
you know and i i i was using short-term
notes to borrow money to flip the house
and make a profit i made a profit on
almost every deal i did
and i still went broke
because the bank got nervous and called
all our notes at one time
and there's a word we use for real
estate that sells really fast
cheap
so we end up selling the real estate for
less than it was owed on it which was
way less than it was worth to keep
foreclosures from happening
and it broke me and i lost everything in
my 20s
okay so that's who's answering your
question i by the way do love real
estate i own several hundred million
dollars worth of real estate today
but after that i quit borrowing money
and so that's the guy and the place that
you called to get your question answered
you need to know that it's in fairness
okay so if you want to do flip this
house with money
uh borrowed money and all that kind of
stuff you're really on the wrong show
you're not going to do what we tell you
to do
okay so having said all that uh
you know here's my answer on duplexes as
your first property
and then here's my answer what we would
do if we woke up in your shoes
the beautiful thing about a duplex is
your renter lives next door
the problem with the duplex is your
renter lives next door
can you tell i've been there okay
so if they want something they can knock
on your door but you also don't have
much trouble collecting the rent because
they're right there cars in the driveway
you know and so we're gonna get our
money uh we don't have to wait on some
uh thing to happen and so it's a you
have to set some relational emotional
boundaries if you're going to do that
that's the problem it's not that bad
the biggest issue i had with duplexes
and i've owned i don't know
probably 100 of them
is that the uh
typically are rental properties
and so typically the buyer when you get
ready to resell them is another investor
who's looking for a deal
the buyer when you get ready to sell
that same square footage of house as a
duplex in a single family is a cute
little couple that wants a picket fence
and a place for their french bulldog to
run around
it feels like a personal attack yeah it
was a personal attack george just take
it for what it is and
they're willing to pay more like retail
and so single family homes of the same
square footage within a two block area
will go up faster in value than duplex
as well because of who your pool of
buyer future buyers are in general
now a nice duplex will outperform a
lousy single-family neighborhood i'm not
talking about it i'm talking about
apples to apples comparison okay
so if you could find a really cool
duplex in an up-and-coming sweet
re-gentrified neighborhood might be a
real seriously good play right versus
buying a dumpy single family okay so
that that's your upsides and downsides
on duplexes what would i do if i woke up
in your shoes and george you chime in
after the personal attack but the uh
is i would pay cash for my first home as
soon as i can and you're very close to
doing that
once you have decided you don't like
losing 50 of your money in bitcoin
and so um how much do you guys have in
crypto just curious
um well since we just got married we
haven't merged all that yet i really
don't know how much he has i have
approximately just shy of 10 grand okay
okay
you guys are
much
you like risk more than i do but i've
been broke
that's another thing you need to keep in
mind i i don't like risk much i don't
like losing money i lost a bunch of it
and it's too hard to make i don't like
losing it
so and and i know that because you're
playing with um lottery money over there
kryptos
you know you've lost your butt on it
and um and i'll stand around acting like
you did something cool you know it's
just it's it's it's horrible so i'd be
getting out of that i'd be buying some
real estate i pay cash for george yeah i
mean you guys don't have a home
currently right primary residence right
so that would be my first goal i
wouldn't mess with the duplex and plus
they're really hard to find right now
because you're not the only one who had
this awesome idea and so if i'm you i'm
getting into a primary residence with
the money you have put a strong down
payment down work on paying that off as
soon as possible and then man the world
is your oyster paycheck getting ready
what i did after i went bro cat was i
got my house paid off took me a little
while
then i saved up i paid cash for my first
rental
not the sexiest answer though
you know what happened you know what
happens with a rental that you have zero
debt on
it cash flows like a
it starts just stacking money up and i'm
able to pay cash for the second one
fairly quick
and you got two of them sitting there
with zero payments
you're just stacking money
and you can buy the third one then
you're just stacking money and ever
since then i've been just stacking money
and then i have some idiot walk up to me
and go you're so lucky luck didn't have
squat to do with it duber
i used a system and a process you know
but dave the renter is going to pay my
mortgage no they don't because runners
don't always pay
can you say pandemic
can you say
eviction moratorium
yeah yeah
yeah you can't get them out and you know
what i had some people that were had
some serious problems during coven and i
could be gentle as a landlord
because you don't need the money because
i didn't have to have the money to eat
you know i have one had cancer
i'll throw somebody's got cancer in the
street
i'm not heartless
now you know you beat your wife and you
don't pay your bills i'll put your crap
in the street
but you know but the thing is
you know you can be gentle when you
don't have any payments and changes
their whole world cap it takes a little
longer
but i've done detailed research and 100
of the foreclosures occur on a home with
a mortgage
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey we want you to stop by and visit us
at ramsey we're in franklin tennessee
just south of nashville if you're ever
around with a huge visitor center you
can watch the show we do the show live
every day for radio podcast and youtube
from one to four central
the cost to watch the show is
astronomical if you want to be in the
studio audience it's somewhere right
around free
okay and so is the coffee so is the
cookies
and uh and you get a free mug too while
you're at it
really yeah did you still give out
coffee mugs they got new fancy ones i
thought i got rid of that that did not
leave the budget oh my god inflation did
not affect that wow i was trying to cut
corner cut costs around here so you
never know you can always get rid of me
in the lobby also of ramsey solutions is
the world famous now debt free stage on
the world famous dead strip free stage
is the world famous matt and mindy
welcome guys how are you hey dave good
to have you guys where do you all live
tulsa oklahoma cool and welcome to
nashville and all the way over here to
do your debt free scream how much did
you pay off
right around 126 127. very good how long
did this take you
about six years and four ish months
six years four months i love it and your
range of income during that time uh
we're around 65 at the time starting and
now we're north of 200.
hey i like that nice job what do you
guys do for a living uh we own our own
construction company now as of june of
21. ah yeah okay so do some owner's rep
work commercial construction consulting
and um just uh that was part of the part
of the plan uh we didn't know it but god
did
yeah and you got yeah good timing huh
yes sir yeah wow good for you guys well
congratulations congratulations what
kind of debt was your 127 000
um started out with some credit card
debt that was the first one we knocked
out then
we did a purchase to home
and uh bought a or had some home
renovations you know about five five
grand in that and then
over a hundred in student loan debt oh
sally bay
and uncle navient uncle navient oh ugly
uncle navient oh my gosh way to go guys
what in the world happened that set you
guys ablaze six years ago
well actually the story starts way
before that um probably 11 years ago we
attended a wonderful church when we
lived in kansas city and they mentioned
actually it was a sermon a dave ramsey
you know sermon and so that was when we
first saw you and heard you heard about
you and got total money makeover and
um then attended a live event while we
were there this is all before we had
kids so that kind of lit the fire which
church uh
at the time it was indian creek
community church yeah okay um and then
it's since changed names but shout out
to our pastor steve southards yeah um
and then we
uh that lit the fire that really like it
just spoke to us it spoke to all of our
needs we had so many dreams in our heart
for owning a business one day matt
actually was in chiropractic school
which is what all the debt was for or oh
my gosh yeah
so
and didn't finish
chiropractic school sets you up
perfectly for construction it sure does
well what we realized was we always
wanted to own a business and run a
business and um we just didn't know
quite how god was going to lead us down
a different path um and so it's been
really neat to uh look back on that and
realize like these dreams that were put
in our heart
now are coming to fruition in a
different way than we expected but um
but it's been so wonderful yeah yeah you
look back you see god's fingerprints all
over it all over but in the middle of it
you're going what yeah exactly left turn
right turn what yeah yeah wow yeah that
was over a decade ago yeah six years ago
something clicked so we were kind of
daveish i guess you could say we paid
off quite a bit before before the six
years um a good a good chunk
um but we kind of you know we bought the
house we kind of did things out of order
we weren't really you know weren't quite
as um on on track as we should be light
dave light
different than davis ramsey lights
better than bud yeah yeah yeah and so uh
so we um
we
got like i don't know we got kind of a
fire lit in this we ended up wanting to
lead an fbu class we thought that's
going to really like shift our mindset
back to walking the walk talking the
talk um so that was really cool because
you can't lead it and be a hypocrite
right well and also shout out to our
current church in tulsa is life church
we're life church members i know you
know our pastor craig rochelle craig and
amy a good friend and so um there was
another push for
fpu and um and all of that and so
um that really inspired us to get
focused um so we were back on track
focused on everything for a couple of
years and then um
then covered well actually before cove
would happen we had we had we have a few
kids
and so we uh along the way along the way
yeah so there was there were some pauses
and the baby steps
um to set money aside for that there was
cash flow the kids cash flow the kids we
you know we had a sinking fund for
vehicle expenses
that you know i mean it happened so we
we had our emergency plan her emergency
savings that thousand dollars we saved
up but then also you know we we we're
driving you know
we were driving some clunkers at times
and and those needed fixed but so we
just set up a sinking fund that that um
we put towards that you know vehicle
expenses so we had about four cars that
we had to cash flow and you know
switch out because they were high
mileage you know cars during that time
couple babies during that time kind of
had to pause on the baby steps
well then um things started to be a
little unsure with um with work and so
um
we started we kind of felt like we
needed to pause the baby steps and start
saving up money
um just um just as a kind of a caution
and um then covet hit and we thought
this is why okay this is why we this is
probably wise we
paused on the baby steps and saved up
money um matt's salary got cut
by about 25 during that time which was
really hard luckily we were on your plan
so it didn't it just changed our margin
it didn't quite mess with our budget too
much so we're grateful for that
um and then
we uh
things got back on track with his salary
but it still felt a little
you know
a little off at work so that led you to
opening the company yeah yeah so um i
actually attended another uh
an event by a wild at heart event um
that some guy or a guy at my church
actually our first the first fbu class
that we attended was john there no no
sir no there was there's yeah it was a
small event there outside of tulsa okay
um and so we
you know i kind of went into it thinking
i i just felt like god was moving um and
i didn't know what was happening you
know i didn't really know but i came
home that sunday evening and i said i i
think i think we're going to do this
yeah and so we came on baby came on and
so we set a plan in place i love it and
um
you know you know there was a lot of
unknowns insurance um you know oh
there's like 9 000 yeah employees um you
know how are we going to do this so what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is now that you've done it
stand on the same page
all the way through all this stuff yeah
i say commitment too i mean i feel like
you have to be committed you have to
decide
take it off the table i know i hear that
all of you no i'm kidding
i know you hear that all the time no
you're right
that like you take take debt off the
table but really i mean when you commit
to it yeah it's not going to be perfect
there's going to be mess-ups there's
going to be things that um come at you
but how does it feel now that you're
free it's incredible i mean it's been
up with their names and ages all right
we got oliver
he's almost nine we got lewis he is
seven we got genevieve she is five and
we've got little josephine
two and a half yeah beautiful they're so
cute that's so fun we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure
thanks dave uh also another copy of uh
ramsey plus a one-year subscription you
can give that away because you guys are
old-time fbu people yeah you'll find
somebody that you can bless with a
one-year subscription to financial peace
university and total money makeover same
thing you'll be able to give that away
i'm so proud of y'all thank you well
done you guys are beautiful incredible
family very well played
very very well done all right it's mandy
and mindy and the gang 127 000 paid off
in six years and four months making 65
to 200. count it down let's hear a dead
scream
three two one
[Applause]
i love it
another family tree changed boom just
like that incredible this is the ramsey
shaft
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
ellen is in chicago hi ellen welcome to
the ramsey show
all right hang on a second
like this they they didn't tell me that
uh
i'll tell you what i'll put you on hold
and i'll go back and talk to kaden in
lincoln nebraska then hey caden what's
up
hey dave how's it going good how can i
help
yeah so i am 21 and i'm about to
graduate college and it's always been a
dream of mine to own a mustang
and i wanted your opinion on how much i
could spend on that without messing up
any of my other financial goals
give me money
yeah so i'm gonna graduate debt free in
december
and thanks to my parents and then i
worked through high school to help
contribute to that
i have about 13 000 in a glass ira and
about 14 in the bank 14 grand
and you're graduating from
[Applause]
did you say college or high school
college with a degree in what
ag business
cool have you got a job
yeah so i have a job lined up starting
in september
and so that will be a full-time job as i
finish up school part-time good for you
how much will you be making
so that will be about 45 days salary and
then i'll go up from there with
commission and bonuses good for you well
done what are you driving now
uh so right now i have a subaru
crosstrek and
i'm using it for my internship and then
i would sell that to buy the mustang
yeah what's it worth
about 13 grand okay all right well i
love cars
so i get your dream okay
uh unless you're talking about the new
mustang which i think is ugliest crud
but anyway i love cars
uh the uh
and you know i got a weak spot for boats
i just got some mastercraft boats i
always wanted a mastercraft ski boat and
i've had mastercraft ski boats for years
and i just got the brand new ones
they're just amazing so i love things
with motors i'm a redneck i love them
okay so i'm with you um
the uh but but what i have learned is is
that i want my dreams to be done in such
a way that they don't become a nightmare
is that okay
exactly which is kind of what you asked
you just said a different way i want to
do it i want to do it wisely is what you
asked so what are you thinking you
should do what do you want to do
so what i want to do is i'll get a
company vehicle with this new job in
september and so i can use that for
personal use and so practicality doesn't
have to be a consideration okay and so i
would sell my current vehicle and then
i'm trying to figure out how much more i
can put on that and get you know newer
better faster
you know how that goes
okay so i mean you've looked at mustangs
you've been thinking about this what are
you thinking about
i'm thinking about 20 to 25 000 but to
me i've always been kind of a tight wad
and so that's that's a big number for me
okay
i think you're in range um the range
that we use is a you pay cash
and you'll be debt free when you do all
of this if i understood you're right
correct
yep
and b
you don't want vehicles things with
motors and wheels to add all together
because they all go down in value to be
more than half of your annual income
if you're making 45 and you have a car
that's worth 20
i mean that's okay it's not the end of
the world
i'm glad you didn't call me up and tell
me you wanted to lease a new one
yeah i mean i knew what you'd say to
that one good i'm glad saved us both a
lot of pain
so here's my thing that answered me
you've got the company car so this one's
going to be sitting around a whole bunch
isn't it it's just kind of a weekend
driver
essentially
yep yeah
so in that case it makes me less excited
you know you're not going to be driving
it all that much so to spend 20 000 i
would just look at your other goals you
said you had other financial goals right
you're probably wanting to buy a house
one day
you might need to save up for a wedding
one day you have other things going on
your life you want to be able to invest
15 into retirement with your new job so
i would just factor all of those things
in before making this purchase i still
think it's a wise purchase based on the
parameters you set out but i would also
look at the opportunity cost of what my
other goals are and what my future looks
like yeah i
so
here's the thing there's nothing
devastatingly stupid about what you're
talking about doing
but you are parking twenty thousand
dollars in something that's not going to
go anywhere
and it is most of your net worth
okay
so it would be okay
to delay the purchase of the mustang
since it is kind of a toy in a sense
here
a a year and let's see what a year
brings
and you might end up delaying it two
years let's see what two years brings
and that kind of thing i'm not saying
don't live your dreams
not saying you've always wanted to own a
mustang that's fine
um
now if you'll select
the particular mustang that you're gonna
buy very carefully
in terms of mileage cleanliness and the
uniqueness of the particular car what
it's got in it how it's built all that
kind of thing that could ensure that you
could resell it quickly and easily if
you ever wanted to
say
fall in love and you wanted to buy a
house with said queen more than you
wanted said car
and you can unload the car at that point
don't get too attached to this crap it's
car and right now it's not a great time
to buy a car so that's another reason to
wait and that 14 000 you have in cash
that sounds like it's your emergency
fund and so we need to save up outside
of that so that when you sell your
subaru you have the cash on hand with
that money to then purchase it in cash
yeah i'm probably waiting till spring
and let's have a little cooling off
period and i might wait till the next
spring
but but i think you're you know you're
on the right track and the ratios we're
giving you are there if it's a toy pay
cash for it never have more than 50 of
your
income tied up in things that go down in
value that have motors and wheels and i
got a lot of junk with motors and wheels
now because i'm kind of i like you know
i like stuff that goes wooden wooden you
know i just do and so
uh but that's but it's a very very small
percentage of my world overall and that
helps me stay sane and wise and all of
those kinds of things ellen is with us
now in chicago hi ellen how are you
yes um i'm gonna try and make this as
quick as i can me and my husband are 57
we are three thousand dollars away from
paying young
baby step two good
and i'm having a problem doing a mental
switch
to be
as intense
for baby step three
how are you 57 and never had a
devastating emergency
you should be able to look back on your
life and go i really need a rainy day
fund because sometimes it freaking rains
well it's more that there's a length of
time taking to be taken to do
how long is it going to take
about a year nah
how much are you trying to save up for
this emergency fund
around 25 000. and what's your household
income
um thousands why does it take a year so
you have no payments and you have 170
000 in an income why take a year to come
up with 25 grand
i don't know i just
my brain is still set you're making 14
grand a month
yeah so let's let's
call it six months and be done with it
okay yeah it gets to 25 000 in the bank
and then you'll relax in a place you
didn't even realize you were uptight
yeah most people do baby step three in
six months and you don't have an average
income you have a above average income
and so it tells me you can do this
faster
yeah we have a above average income as
long as i don't go out for short-term
disability again
um
how often has that happened
um it's happened well i'm on it right
now i'm just about to end it right now
and it happened
twice last year
okay so your income's really not 175 000
right now
um
no it's not
what is your what is your portion of the
175
around okay just got i just got a price
a price listen to me
i know you've got 64 000 myself
okay so he makes a hundred and twenty
hundred and ten yeah okay
okay so it might take you eight months
instead of seven months let's pretend
you had zero income
um let's call it eight months with zero
income you with 25 000 making 110 in
eight months but no payments yeah you
can do this and by the way your life is
an emergency right now why would you not
want an emergency fund more than
anything
you definitely need an emergency fund
you have all kinds of motivation look in
the mirror i mean right now you're like
i've been out three times on short-term
disability
this is a person who needs an emergency
fund yes go get you one girl you'll feel
better i promise
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we're here to help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships the phone number
here is triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five
two two
five
well george uh ripping people off
with bad
lending practices predatory lending
practices
even when you give it a cool tech name
is no longer cool that's right buy now
pay later that's what this is all about
i didn't rip anyone off just to be clear
here klarna here's here's the headline
from morning
klarna's life which means nothing no
what's the word mean nothing nothing
it's just a hip hip it means that now
you gonna pay payments when you should
have not bought the shirt if you
couldn't afford the freaking shirt
oh my god here's what they're saying
klarna's layoffs signal a broader buy
now pay later slow down oh
feels so bad there's an increase in
common sense
and here's what it goes on to say
these companies are watching their rapid
gains crumble by now pay later giant
klarna europe's largest private tech
firm said yesterday it was laying off 10
percent of the company's roughly 7 000
employees
wow
700
firm after pay number of these startups
its point of sale installment loans is
what it is last year u.s consumers spent
over 20 billion dollars
through these services
the ceo says the war in ukraine
what
oh that's what they're they're blaming
it soaring inflation
and likely recession
as reason for the
cuts i i mean
there's
the reason you're cutting your employees
is because your product is not selling
people didn't quit borrowing money for
their shirt on klarna
because of the ukrainian war
you it's a great reason double ducking
goober
seriously
that's so lame i got breakfast this
year's from after pay my biscuit allowed
me to do four interest-free payments of
375 using after pay on a biscuit
can you believe that
wow biscuit a literal biscuit i was
shocked and uh so here's what's
happening so mr ceo it's not the ukraine
it's the fact that people woke up the
fact you were screwing them and they got
tired of financing their biscuit
this is why you're going to lay people
off there's an end
another study says there's an increase
in wisdom and common sense directly
correlated to the loss of claris 700
employees oh my god
this is four out of five dentists say if
you brush your teeth they won't fall out
it's amazing how that works so we've
been talking about this before it was
cool steering people away from it we did
a whole episode on the fine print about
buying out yes george was he was a he
was a man i called him he was early to
the party so here's what they're saying
buy now pay later companies are dealing
with another threat regulation numerous
us and uk agencies have launched
investigations into the company's
potentially predatory lending practices
accusing them of irresponsibly allowing
young consumers to rack up debt
wow oh i mean
you're saying it's bad to finance a
biscuit is this what we're saying
they're finally realizing this predatory
lending
because they try to act like the good
guys that's what frustrates me the most
about your honor i'm in bankruptcy court
today because of my biscuit problem
375 40 payments first of all that's an
expensive biscuit i gotta say
but here's what happens retailers can
charge more for their products because
the price looks lower to these young
consumers who go well i can fit 375 in
my budget why not i mean it's almost
impossible to pull something up online
right now that they don't go for easy
payments
and you know you're four dollars and
twenty-two you were around when this
originally like you can't
you can't afford any purse print i mean
come on well dave it freeze money in my
budget they're they're trying to help
you achieve financial freedom see
ukrainian war it's throwing everything
off
it's insane sorry for the ukrainian or i
don't like it i don't mean that i'm not
making fun of the ukrainian people love
their good but you can't blame your
company's failures on that no these
companies they they try to act like
they're the good guys in the lending
industry because they go well we don't
do interest we don't do all these fees
we're better than the credit card
companies we're not payday lenders yeah
let me give you the principle okay
19
okay
take us back
23 years old
i bought a house
believe it or not
for eight thousand dollars wow
i spent twelve thousand dollars to fix
it up it was pretty dumpy
so i got twenty thousand bucks in this
house
i sold it to a guy
for thirty four thousand dollars who
went and got an fha loan this is
it ain't much of a house even in 83
that's not much of a house okay
you know what he did
he didn't get the fha loan
his grandpa loaned the money
he turned around and he sold this house
that i had 20 in sold to him for 30 for
50
to a guy
on payments
zero interest
500 down
wow
now you tell me that's zero interest
because the appraisal on the house was
34.
he sold it for 50.
is that zero interest
no
well the contract said it was zero
interest
this is what clarina does it's a modern
day version of that crap
okay just mark it up
double
mark it up 25
mark it up
18
and then call it no interest
we're not charging any interest how
could we be doing predatory lending
yes you are boys and girls we've all got
different traps and so not all of them
some of them are interest-free some of
them are fee-free but if you miss a
payment that is where the apr kicks up
way higher than credit cards some of
these are 30 percent apr well and they
got more fees than a french poodle i
mean it's fifi fifi everywhere it's just
ridiculous and they're hoping and
banking on the fact that you won't pay
oh yeah because then they get to really
get you with the late charges
so can you tell that we're not sad that
karna's not doing well the reason we're
not sad that karna's not doing well is
clarna doesn't do you well
we don't really care all we want is for
you to win we love you people we want
you to win we're what's known as
consumer advocates we're always going to
be taking up for you telling you that
you're getting screwed here you're
getting screwed there stay away from
these guys they're going to screw you
don't do this it's going to screw you
don't do that if you'll if you'll follow
if you'll just keep from getting screwed
all the time you'll have some money
what's crazy is that they're not going
after the credit card companies these
you know these agencies but they're
going after buying out pay later that
tells you something about how scummy
these companies are and how predatory
they are
capital one's not you know they've got
certain levels of regulation but these
buying out pay later companies here's
what they do to avoid regulation they do
four payments instead of five because
once you do five
now truth and lending there's the truth
and lending act that kicks in whoa i did
not know isn't that wild
fun fact interesting information and
their marketing goes after lower income
it goes after minorities and so they're
starting to get goes after the young and
stupid
gen z if you're young and you're stupid
i was just talking to you
yeah
so you don't have to be done you don't
have to be stupid if you're young and
you don't have to be young if you're
stupid that's true you could be either
one or both
but boy if you're both you are a target
of these people you're the one financing
a biscuit if you're financing a biscuit
you might be stupid
if you're financing a shirt
you might be stupid
you got 17 in the closet
unbelievable
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today a lot of people would
rather spend their weekend doing yard
work than talk about insurance but
here's the deal if you don't take the
time to learn about insurance you're
going to feel like you're getting ripped
off probably because you are
you got to learn about it
insurance is necessary but doing the
wrong stuff is really expensive
we think learning about money should be
simple or even fun our new five-day
guide to insurance called confidence in
your coverage
by our own george campbell makes
learning about insurance quick practical
and you'll even laugh out loud it is
george he's going to make you try to
throw a few jokes yeah he's going to
keep you humorous yeah we understand the
uh
a little little spoonful of sugar helps
the medicine go down and all that right
so every day for five days ramsey
personality george campbell will walk
you through a new insurance topic
unpacking everything you need to know to
get the right coverage it's completely
free to do all of this go to
ramseysolutions.com
confidence
because that's what you need
ramseysolutions.com
confidence our question today comes from
blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey to get
the best deal today's question comes
from kevin in phoenix he says i know you
say to put 20 percent down on a 15-year
fixed rate mortgage but in the market
i'm in it feels unattainable at one
point we hit our savings goal but by the
time we saved up enough the home prices
had jumped way up we're debt free and
we've been renting for a few years and
it just feels like we'll never be able
to buy our first home we're trying to
run the baby steps but don't see the
light at the end of the tunnel right now
is it okay to put less down in order to
get into a house faster or should we
wait for house prices to come down
well
that question at the end there i'll
answer that first uh
maybe both we don't say you have to put
20 down especially on your first home
we say it's ideal to put 20 down because
you avoid pmi private mortgage insurance
which is extra money you pay to protect
the lender not you
so as a first time home buyer i love
that you're trying to follow the baby
steps you're debt-free you're saving up
for this house and so i'm okay with you
putting less down as your down payment
in order to get into this house and yes
you probably should wait for the housing
market to cool off a little bit so
you're not putting 100 over asking with
no inspection don't do stupid stuff like
that yeah uh prices are not going to
come down kevin
if you're waiting on prices to come down
you're not going to buy a house ever
prices are not coming down
they are going to slow
the rate at which they are increasing
though that's what georgia's referring
to when the market cools off
right now
asking price means suggest you start
bidding here
and uh we want to get out of that kind
of thing and you're probably going to
see that we've seen interest rates tick
up the market has slowed down we seem to
be moving into
our second quarter of contraction in the
economy this is known as a recession
and uh
the biden administration seems bound and
determined to create one so it looks
like we're going to be there
and uh that that's where i mean
politics aside it's just observation
and uh the so i think you're probably
gonna see
calming down but we've never seen house
prices go down
in the modern america like since the
1930s except one time
and that was for about six or eight
months
in 2008
when the bubble burst on the housing
market
and it was a t it was a financing bubble
it wasn't a real estate bubble
and so some markets uh phoenix was
particularly hit
las vegas was particularly hit a few
other major cities that were super hot
they retr they contracted
and the prices actually went down
but that's the only time i've seen that
and i've had a real estate license 30
years i can't find it anywhere
uh since the what the late 30s
1930s so 100 years almost
uh and so i don't think you're gonna see
house prices go down but we did have
nine was it 20 20 house prices went up
32 percent right yeah it's crazy and
then 21 they went up 14 and they're
predicting in 22 for them to go up 7 so
we're seeing a a sl the rate of increase
is is less and i think we're going to
continue to see that but i don't think
you're going to see house prices lower
so yes i would buy
uh but don't buy more than a fourth of
your income on a 15 year fix regardless
of what you put down and just understand
you are signing up for pmi which is
about seventy five dollars a month per
hundred thousand borrowed so you buy
three hundred thousand dollar house
you're paying an extra 225 dollars a
month for insurance that is a
foreclosure insurance that
pays the mortgage company if they
foreclose on you it does nothing for you
but that's what private mortgage
insurance is pmi so if you can put five
to ten percent down and it's still a
quarter your take-home pay and a 15-year
fixed rate then beat that thing down and
get it paid down so you can get rid of
that pmi even after you buy
turn around get rid of it yeah that's
fine i don't mind that
and then the other thing you can do is
you could
adjust your
desires
but dave it's my dream house it's called
yeah it's a nightmare right now it's
called contentment
okay
the dream house for someone in 1962 was
1 000 square foot
one and a half baths
story
one car garage one car in the driveway
that was the standard of living of the
average american in 1962.
today
it is a microwave a towel warming drawer
granite countertops
three-car garage
with electric garage door openers which
when i was a child were only for rich
people
and if you don't have one on your house
now it means you're poverty-stricken
a skylight and a jacuzzi oh gotta have
that skylight
that's living a dog wash
oh that's true i've seen those those are
wild i mean this is standard equipment
now three thousand square foot two story
is the average home in america it's
gonna so while house prices have gone up
dramatically since 1962 you can't young
kids can't buy a house like they could
in 1962 the average house price to the
average income is completely out of
whack well the average house is
completely out of whack
by the way
so
there's the problem
contentment is a big deal
so maybe adjust the expectations kevin
and go hey is there a condo we can get
into
so that we can get into this house
sooner because i don't want you waiting
15 years to get into the market people
think our advice is well dave ramsey
wants you to only save up and pay cash
and you got to wait 20 years and you'll
never get a house that's not
you know and by the way you will get a
house so
because lot there's nothing here
stagnant in the whole process though
the the point is you know no one can
afford a car because the value of a car
right now a brand new car as a ratio to
income versus a brand new car in 1970
ratio to income
is completely out of whack well the
stinking car's out of whack too
i mean these cars are
you know they're now 50 60 000 is normal
they're wonderful automobiles but by god
they'll fry an egg while you drive to
work i've never seen they do everything
everything rachel's for you don't even
have to drive anymore they'll drive for
you i mean and you know so here's the
thing
i am not saying you shouldn't have nice
things i'm saying your nice things
shouldn't have you and you need to
kind of adjust your
mind
because normal is such a high standard
of living now
compared to a few years ago that you
cannot use
euro gold statistics
and say that the economy is completely
out of whack and wealth inequality is
lost we've lost our minds because we
haven't what we've lost our minds on is
what we're purchasing
i mean this mastercraft ski boat that i
got
it's like driving a spaceship
it is freaking incredible can you get
that to drive itself because that would
be it's it's amazing piece of equipment
but i can afford it
and that's the difference
you know
and you know if
you need to be able to be making some
money to drive a mastercraft to pull
people around on entertainment when you
say
you don't mean the payments you mean no
i mean but i'm sure god they're fabulous
these cars these cars are fabulous these
houses are fabulous but that doesn't
mean you can afford it
but they that hurt a lot it turns my
feelings i'm really not concerned about
your feelings have long you've been here
george
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today cheryl's in milwaukee hi
cheryl welcome to the ramsey show
thank you for taking my call
[Music]
i'm hoping you can help me decipher on
what we need to do
i'll give you a little background we
have three children um the first one
just graduated from college
second one will be a junior in college
and then third one's in high school
now the first one has nine thousand
dollars left over in
the edvest account
and the second one we
might be like 10
10 to 12 000 short in covering the rest
of
that college education
my husband thinks we should just keep it
in there
i think we should roll it
why would you not rolling
pardon me why would you i mean you're
going to come up short on one and you've
got the money in the other and the other
one's done
right and he he thinks well you know it
it's his money well even though not his
money
he didn't put it in there what if he
wants to what if he wants to you know
for his you know his kids i said well
then we'll start something up when he
has kids i'm not gonna sit on nine grand
and take it out of our
non-existing interest bearing savings
account to pay
come up the shortfall absolutely
is that right yeah am i am i thinking
correctly you are you win the argument
that's a no-brainer we're not going to
go into debt so that this kid can have
it for his grandkids he's got plenty he
didn't put it in there in the first
place
right you can change the beneficiary at
any time i mean we've been very diligent
on making sure we were able to
help our children come out of school
debt-free so once you did that that's
called like a miracle it's wonderful go
yeah so yeah you roll the money and the
other kid gets taken care of and it was
just a calculation rounding error we
round it we roll it and move on
and if there's a pile of money when the
third one comes out just split it three
ways and hand it to them i'm good with
that but
we got to get all three out first
we ought to get all three out first
right
okay
that's what i would do i mean is that
what you're asking
yes that's i mean like you said we are
not worried about the third because
the third one
you know
we've put more money in as our income
has grown so she will have a little bit
more to deal with but
at the end of the day she might have
extra so we would
well all three of mine came out with a
little bit of a surplus and i did not
even it up i just let them keep whatever
was in their surplus and in my case okay
but i didn't come up short on one either
okay if i'd come up short i would have
been
coming up short is because she
the second one's going to private so
it's a little bit
more
okay i mean you but everybody made that
choice together you knew this i mean
no one went oh oh she's in private who
knew i mean you knew you knew she was
there
right yeah right so yeah i mean that's
just in order you made the decision to
do this when you made the decision allow
her to go that more expensive school
because you knew you were going to pay
for it it's just a matter of
right yeah so i i
pay for it it's college funds college
fund kids college are paid for boom now
next what are we doing okay that's what
i'm moving on it's a simple answer yeah
that's what i would do
529s can be transferred to any kid adult
or any member of the family it can be
niece aunt uncle men mom and dad very
generous mom can go back and get her
masters with
what's left over from the kids for 529
now and a lot of people don't know if
you get a scholarship you can take that
money out of the 529 against the
scholarship
yep tax-free tax-free tax-free the
amount of the scholarship so you get a
13 000 scholarship pull 13 out of the
old 529 no taxes
no penalties
no problems a lot of things you can do
with it eric is with us eric is in
wichita kansas hi eric how are you
hey dave and george how are you guys
doing this afternoon better than we
deserve what's up
hey man i've got a just a question about
uh
our family situation my wife and i um we
have a little girl that's three i'm
gonna be three in june and then my wife
is expecting another little one in
october wonderful
yeah we're excited about that but i've
just got a question about uh we're
completely out of debt we're in baby
steps four five and six and just trying
to figure out whether we should kind of
halt those and start stacking up some
cash or
i'm thinking about
being out of debt i have about 1700 a
month that i can put towards
um pretty much whatever i need to but i
don't know if i should start paying off
my house or if i should um stack the
cash in savings and
i just wanted some advice on that i
guess what are you stacking the cash for
oh for for our second baby
you have an emergency fund
yeah we did it's up 20 000 you have a
job why is your second baby you need an
emergency fund
i i was just like if there was
something that went wrong medically or
whatever i don't know um how much is in
your emergency fund
about 20 000 you have health insurance
yeah my wife's on the christian health
care ministries
okay all right
um unless there's something that you're
that you think that that's not going to
cover
that is a realistic expectation
i would simply continue to follow the
plan do you have an out-of-pocket
maximum on that
um so it's like a 500 deductible but we
have to pay everything up front in cash
and get reimbursed
yeah they reimburse it basically so
yeah i mean is there any difficulties
with the pregnancy at all
uh not that we know of right now we just
found out the gender this uh this last
actually yesterday so oh that's fine
yeah well yeah i think you're being a
good dad to be careful and to be wise
and to be thoughtful about this
but uh you've got a good emergency fund
i'm not worried about if you want to
build up the emergency fund a little bit
baby comes and then throw the money on
at the house later in october that's not
the end of the world but i don't think
it's necessary here it's not if it'll
help you sleep better at night to put
that 1700 away for the next five months
until the baby gets here that's 8 500
bucks and baby's great then we go 8 500
bucks going towards the principal on the
mortgage or drop it on two college funds
and let's get going you know whatever
baby step five right either one's fine
yeah you could drop five grand on two
college funds and go a long long way
um you know for christmas
i've been teaching you guys this class
um i teach math at a little high school
around here and yeah i've been teaching
your personal finance class and i just i
watched the show for about a year and a
half and i've seen different people ask
questions and i just wasn't sure so i
appreciate you guys time today well
thank you sir thank you for teaching the
class to high schoolers that's a big
deal man
lisa is in atlanta georgia hi lisa
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much um good afternoon
dave and george
i appreciate you taking my call
so my question is
i am looking to change jobs i currently
have a job that ties me to a radius
in atlanta
and my actual home is outside of the
radius
so i'm looking to change to 100 remote
job that will let me and my husband live
in the same home
and for me to be able to to be with my
family that lives in pennsylvania
so the two opportunities that i have in
front of me
one job let's just call it the
retirement company they specialize in
retirement plans
the pay is a little bit less
than what i am currently making
but the 401k
is is good there's an the other
opportunity is in medical supplies the
pay is a little bit more but the 401k is
not as good what is not as good on a 401
so the 401 the 401k for the medical
company is they'll do a 50 match
up to eight percent
and then it's a vested amount
so you have a vested schedule
the other one the retirement company
it's three percent off the top and then
a six percent match
and what is the end what is the income
with the two
um
what would you be making with the
retirement company would you be making
the medical supply company so the 19
with the retirement company medical
supplies be 21.
i do the medical supplies
i do the medical supply i don't think it
makes that much difference so 401k is
not that big a deal here the spread on
it's not there
and i think there's more upside with
your medical supply i think the other
one sounds like a bureaucratic corporate
job to me
i'm guessing i'm reading into things
you're saying between the lines and the
sentences
but that's my gut yeah i'd also go which
one do i want to do more no there's that
do you want to be in medical supply do
you want to be in retirement ken coleman
on me there's an idea yeah i don't know
all right hold on we're gonna send you a
copy of ken's book from paycheck to
purpose you usually don't make a
decision on a 401k you make it on other
things that are more important this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
proverbs 15 1 a gentle answer turns away
wrath but a harsh word stirs up anger
ralph waldo emerson said you cannot do a
kindness too soon
because you never know how soon it will
be too late
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today allison is in henderson
kentucky hey allison how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
good um so i have a question um in 2001
my employer at the time
they
had uh anthem insurance and that company
i guess
by demutualization awarded anyone that
had that insurance
some
shares correct some stock and so
it has now in the past few years it's
grown so my question is is
i have enough where
if i sell it i could
pay off my house
well it would leave me about six months
to pay on my own
but i was wondering if it would be
beneficial to sell it pay off my house
and then i'd be debt-free after six
months yes um
but just paying that capital gains tax
that would be
so
do it
what's the stock worth
um
the total amount that's worth now
uh it's like 28
five somewhere around there okay
let's uh visit your kitchen table with
me in your mind
okay i want you to see thirty thousand
dollars piled up in the middle of that
table
right
you have two choices with this pile of
thirty thousand dollars
you can pay it down on your house
or you can buy anthem stock
right which one you're going to do
um i'd rather pay down the house it's
kind of a no-brainer
you would never have bought anthem stock
it was given to you as a part of the
process you ended up in it by default
you never sat down five years ago and
went oh i dream someday that i have
thirty thousand dollars in anthem stock
that is not how this happened
what's left on the mortgage
uh it's about 29.5
okay yeah you're gonna be there in no
time kiddo it's gonna be so cool and
it's a couple of grand in capital gains
right yeah
that's what i'm assuming i don't really
know how to figure all that but i'm
assuming so well i'm guessing it's a
hundred percent gain it may even be
ordinary income
um
the capital gain will be on what it went
up since you got it
but it was given to you as an award
correct
right you paid nothing for it
correct so your gain is a hundred
percent
right and so 30 times
is 4 500 bucks probably 4 000 bucks
probably something like that so
get get tax advice get your tax advisor
to tell you how much to set back before
you send too big a check to the
uh
mortgage company they don't have enough
pay your tax bill
right but then put the rest of it on the
house let's get the house paid off what
do you make a year
um well it depends if i have overtime or
not so anywhere between uh 60 and 65 000
good for you
and you have a paid for house by
christmas
yeah
awesome it's gonna feel so good
i hope so
allison in our world this is called a
no-brainer have at it kiddo lisa's in
atlanta hi lisa welcome to the ramsey
show
think you already took my call baby we
we got her oh well good okay we've done
everything we needed to do she's just
hanging around pretty impressive
appreciate lisa still listening in yeah
thanks cleaning wisdom i appreciate you
hanging with us open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five all right george that
technique i just used
is called a sunk cost analysis oh the
kitchen table analogy comes from the
harvard
investment newsletter
and it really like in that case the
article harkens back to
someone says
i don't want to i bought this stock
for 120 dollars it's gone down five
years ago to eighty thousand
and i don't really wanna sell it until
it comes back
up above what i paid for it
i don't wanna take the loss
what do i do
and you don't make the decision on
whether to keep eighty thousand dollars
worth of stock
based on what you paid for it
you make the decision on whether to keep
eighty thousand twenty eight thousand
five hundred dollars worth of stock
based on what the future
is what the best future is for the money
now if you had eighty thousand dollars
in the middle of the kitchen table and
you said i wouldn't buy that stock again
by not selling it you effectively bought
it again every morning
yeah every morning
making the decision to keep it it's as
if you're buying it yet again right
and so you know i wouldn't ever buy it
well why i'm not sure it's going to go
back up but you're waiting on it to go
back up well this is a dumb process and
this is the way the human mind works and
so the guy writing this article was
making a really good psychological point
and and he trained the kids in the mba
classes the masters in business classes
that when someone started doing an
analysis based on what they paid for it
which is called the sunk costs
that's history it's over doesn't matter
what you paid for it all that matters is
where it's going in the future
and if someone started doing the
analysis based on sunk costs the whole
class was trained to yell sunk costs
that's fun and shut the whole thing down
just to get people out of that mindset
of thinking i i'm you know what and you
can do this with a personal item you can
do it with anything you say if i had
that money would i buy that again
a lot of times people have moved over
the years they move out of a house
they get transferred to another city the
real estate market's not hot like it is
right now they can't sell the house
they put a renter in it
they call me up seven years later and go
i got a rental house in abilene texas
and i live in memphis tennessee
what what you know should i sell that
one yes why because you didn't buy it in
the first place for this if you started
over today you wouldn't buy that
property you you you became a landlord
by default
it's a sunk cost
the how you got there is irrelevant the
only thing that's relevant on the
decision on whether to keep it or not is
the future
and the future says if i live in memphis
tennessee i wouldn't go to abilene texas
to buy my rental property it's it's
devoid of common sense
and so
if you wouldn't buy it again
today because of its future
whatever it is the boat and the driveway
then it's time to sell it
but if you go no i love that boat and i
couldn't get another one for you know
that amount of money and our family gets
enjoyment out of that and i can afford
it and i'm not getting rid of my boat i
love my boat and i if i didn't have it
i'd go buy one just like it then you
would keep that boat because because of
its future though
not because of its past wow
that's an interesting one i like that
analogy it definitely helps clear the
emotion out of the picture and just look
at things logically yeah and you know
and and some things
uh this would lead you to keep um
to use some good emotional intelligence
and keep a nostalgic out item
when you go okay
that's my grandmother's wedding ring
it's an heirloom
and i could sell that diamond ring for
about ten thousand dollars okay
but there's a you could never get that
back
it's gone
out of your entire family lineage
forever
you know changes things i'm not selling
that
i'm i'm not selling that i'm selling a
lot of things i'm not showing that but
people justify when it's a it's a truck
and they go dave it's my dream truck i
can't sell it
you're telling me there's not another
tacoma down the road well it's not that
special that's not that that's a
different thing that it's
not a singular item i mean now if it's a
truck that um was in 1962
and you and your dad rebuilt it in the
garage when as a as a antique mod
and you know you've been working you
worked on it for 10 years from the time
you were 10 until the time you were 20
and then you went off to college and
your dad passed away and left the truck
to you uh i ain't selling that truck
you know that's like them that's like
grandma's diamond ring then you know uh
but but if it's just something you
bought three weeks ago or five years ago
and you have zero attachment to it other
than you think it's cool
that's a different thing then yeah i'm
selling i'm going to sell i'm selling
the horse camel right
oh gosh i was going to go there dave but
i didn't i refrained you held back but i
couldn't i learned horses are
sentimental last week and they are
family and they are basically kids
not my words not my words well it's uh
george you should be just
poor i mean they're calling it horse
gate dave horse horse canceled culture
you're gone for a week and this is what
hamill's horse i never thought that's
how it goes it's on youtube look it up
camels for escape
they're gonna have to upload a video
titled that so someone's gonna say this
is awesomeness i'm just telling you that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you